- Hello, I am Tylor Kim.
I'm from Samsung Electronics.
Yeah, today people started our subject,
let me introduce myself.
Yeah, I am Kyotack Tylor Kim.
I'm a lead engineer of Core SRE Part.
I'm operating some project
from Samsung Electronics,
just like Bixby and Galaxy AI,
which are the some main AI
services in Samsung Electronics.
And also, I am engaged with
some vision critical projects,
just like Samsung Wallet and
Samsung accounts like that.
I will touch about the example
of this project more
during these sessions.
Yeah, today's agenda is
how Samsung use AI agent
to optimize infrastructures
that scale with the Cast AI.
Yeah, I'm coming from Samsung Electronics.
I'm not an employee of Cast AI,
so I'm just explain my experience,
during using Cast AI only, yeah.
Yeah, people touch the main item.
I explained the Samsung
Electronics in glimpse.
Yeah, this company is established in 1969,
and this company grown
into more than 260,000 peoples worldwide.
And my company produce some mobile phone,
based on the Galaxy brand,
and also making some visual displays
and home appliance as well.
Also, put the P2B businesses,
and we are making semiconductors,
and it is also indispensable part
of the Samsung Electronics operations.
In bottom of that slide,
and also tell is some R&D centers,
and the each R&D center
is established globally.
And so this R&D center
focus on some localizations,
and also, they have some
specialized features just like AI
or SRE like that.
Yeah, here is the challenge of my company,
and we need to operate
massive-scale Kubernetes operations,
and so scale and complexity
is very challenging for us
because we are running our applications
on top of multi-cloud.
It's AWS, Google Cloud, and Azure,
and Samsung Cloud as well.
This makes operating more complex.
We should do considering
more infrastructures code,
based on the multi-cloud.
We also thinking about some
well-grained security policy
for operators and developers.
And another one is over
than 50 applications running
on top of AWS.
Some applications is
running on top of AWS only,
and some applications
running on top of AWS
and other cloud providers.
And over than 1,000 EK
clusters in our system,
and tens of thousand of
virtual machines nodes,
is learning for our applications.
And the second one is
CPU and GPU workload,
and critical mix of CPU and
GPU workload is very important
to us because we have separated team
for training and inference.
From the training team, they wanted
to have some simply paid
operational requirement.
They want to running their
training infrastructures,
running on top a single
(indistinct) clusters.
In case of inference team,
they want to have some more GPUs
with cost-effective prices
And also, we have a traditional backend
and proton-developing
company and developing teams,
and they also want to have
some unified requirement tools.
Yeah, in second side,
standard cost-saving
limit is also important.
Till last year, we only focus
on the ROI and savings plans
for the cost-saving policy,
and it's not very attractive
because we only have
some commitment to AWS,
we can get on more
cost-effective infrastructures.
But from this year,
we are also considering
spot instance pretty much.
After using the Cast AI solution,
(indistinct) instance is very attractive.
Without any commitment to AWS,
we can get a more cheap
infrastructures by using Cast AI.
Yeah, this is the solution that
and Samsung have some ongoing
project called Agentic AI.
Agentic AI has some separated categories,
just like infrastructures
management and security,
and change management or (indistinct)
and monitoring committee.
And also, Cast AI integration
manages GPU and CPU workload.
I will touch more about this,
and banking optimization for
intelligent workload placement,
is also important.
In right side, center of our Agentic AI,
there is a Cast AI.
Cast AI control the AIOps
and workload simultaneously,
and it supports the AWS, EKS pretty much.
Yeah, here is some key challenges.
Scalability issues, how to
efficiently manage thousands
of diverse workload across the
massive Kubernetes clusters.
And it's a very important thing,
because my operators need
to support Kubernetes portion upgrade.
Everybody knows it's very difficult
because of we spent much time,
and also, there is some
performance bottleneck.
In case of Samsung Wallet,
for the Korean customer tend
to not bring their plastic card
to the market in these days.
So when the Samsung Wallet is impaired,
they can't buy anything from the market.
So kudos the Samsung Wallet project,
performance bottleneck or impairment
or latency is very critical.
And integration complexity.
As like mentioned earlier,
my company making us some over
the 50 applications on cloud.
So in this case, simple
architecture is a very important,
so I'm thinking about the Cast AI.
We put only one component
in our infrastructures.
We can easily achieve our AI
Agentic architecture in place.
Yeah, here is some technical solutions,
automation driven by AI,
and using Samsung's AI agent
to continuously optimize
cloud in real-time.
Yeah, as like mentioned earlier,
some change management and
security and (indistinct)
and other AI agent is running,
and they cooperate, and
on top of this AI agent,
there is also supervisor agent is running.
So when the implementation is done,
and I believe this operation
system will be very smart.
Next one is a Cast AI integration,
leveling intelligent
to automation pictures
to scale fast and automatically
and right size workload in real-time.
Yeah, so when the implement Cast AI,
operational engineers don't
need to operate anymore,
and the automatically Cast AI,
controlled our infrastructures.
And the next one is the
impacting optimizations.
I believe that when someone
considering Cast AI first,
in this case, they easily tend to do focus
on those instance only.
But I had some purity in my team,
and the result was pretty good.
When we are only focused on
the bin packing automation
by using Cast AI, the cost
to saving is more than 30%.
It's very crazy, so I
think we are using Cast AI,
and (indistinct) simultaneously,
the cost-saving output
will be more good, I think.
Yeah, I am gonna touch about the result
and picture outlooks of
Samsung Electronics as well.
Yeah, quantifiable impact.
Yeah, reduce the operational overhead.
AI-driven automation, streamless
infrastructure management,
is very important,
because when I installed
the Cast AI solutions,
after that, we can easily figure
out our status and progress
by using monitoring of Cast AI.
I believe that monitoring dashboard
of Cast AI is pretty beautiful,
and I'm also talking about this aspect
to Cast AI people as well.
And cost manual workup scaling,
provisioning and optimization
is also important.
This tool is very important
to for the operational team.
I have over than 50 silos,
and I implemented Cast AI.
After that, they do not need
to monitoring every morning.
So it's also very important.
And next one is improve
the application efficiency
and real-time optimization,
right sizes, resources continuously.
And this means cast AI is AI agent,
always checking our workload,
and sometimes, sharing
the some number of node,
or sometimes scaled out
the number of node sizes.
And the next one is elevate
over and under-provisioning.
We can use all of the
resource in our physical load.
And this is a very important aspect,
and significant cost reductions,
combines the AI automations
and the smart bin packing and spot usage.
And the combination of these three aspect,
make a much cost-saving
outcomes in our company,
and also, enables substantial savings,
across Kubernetes environment.
Yeah, and automation
means that we can focus
on other things in our company,
and usually, we can focus on
the creating other agent job.
We can make some additional
environment for AI operating.
And so this is also significant
cost-reduction as well.
Yeah, here is the future
outlook of my company.
AI-driven autonomy
and moving toward pretty
autonomous cloud operation.
This is the final goal from
the logs, from the Cast AI,
we are getting some more
information of our infrastructures,
and by using the kinds of log systems,
and we can create a more
advanced AI autonomy.
Also, minimal human
interventions required.
In case of mission-critical project,
we needed to monitoring our
system 24 hours, seven days.
That it does a very critical
aspect for the operation,
because of human beings can't focus
on the monitoring every time.
So when we introduced the Cast AI,
after that, we can minimal
human intervention required
in our team.
Second one is industry standard.
Defining new benchmark for
efficiency and scalability,
will be held last few years.
For example, pay the attention
or mixed (indistinct)
could be a benchmark,
and they're dominant in this area.
And that these kinds of
changes very big impact
to our infrastructures.
And so Samsung Electronics is more focused
on these kinds of change,
and we are going to adopt new technology
in our GPU processing as well.
Next one is driving cost-effective,
AI-powered cloud operations.
Cost-effective means
we can use the clearly
optimized infrastructures,
and that is based on the Cast AI product.
And also, we are also more focused
on the AI-powered automation
operations as well.
Lastly, unified optimization
is very interested
in my team,
expanding AI automation across
the CPU and GPU workload.
You can see the GB200 and
GB300 during this re:Invent,
and it's excellent combination
of the CPU and GPU.
Also, already we have some GPU
and CPU combination workload
in our systems.
So well organized, this
operation is very important,
I think, as well.
Lastly, delivering
consistent optimization,
across diverse environment.
Multi-cloud is always very challenging.
Sometimes one public
cloud could be impaired.
In this case, we need to
favorable our workload
to other companies,
in this kinds of orchestration
is very challenging
for the operational team.
So we needed to make our
architecture more simple.
So in the middle of our architecture,
and there is Cast AI solutions.
Yeah, this is all of my deck.
If you have any kinds of
questions, just let me know, yeah.
(audience applauding)